from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out the differences
between Hungary Jacks Australia and
Burger King in the US this is food
Wars first things first you might have
noticed there's a difference in the name
here in Australia Burger King operates
under the name Hungry Jacks because when
they first came here their name was
already taken we'll get more into the
history later but when you hear me
saying Hungry Jacks that's why now let's
get into the drinks in Australia our
Hungry Jack strings come in three sizes
small medium and large in the US our
Burger King drinks come in four sizes
the value the small the medium and the
large let's measure them to keep them
honest to be fair to Burger King I
filled these up I think I did a pretty
good job the lid's a little recessed yes
there's ice in there now let's measure
the
lodge I feel like everything is about
four or 5 ounces off our fries or chips
as we like to call them in Australia
come in three sizes small medium and
large our fries come in four sizes the
little value the small the medium and
the large and you know we're going to
weigh them so these portions should
weigh 90 G 116 G and 166 G according to
the hunger Jacks website so let's see if
this is true
that's
convenient both Australia and the US
have the Whopper so let's weigh both of
them and compare all right
here under the nuggets in Australia our
nuggets come in four sizes 3 6 12 and 18
our us nuggets come technically in three
sizes the four piece P the eight piece
which in some part of the countries you
can also get the Fiery nugget version in
eight piece and a 16 piece which was not
available well I want to be in the shot
I'm just kidding cuz this is my new head
shot here in the US we have four sizes
of onion rings again value small medium
and large in Australia our onion rings
come in two sizes a medium and a large
just eyeballing it right now looks like
we have bigger portion size than
Australia I'm going to count out the
Rings in the largest and see how it
compares to theirs so in a large serving
we get 12 onion rings okay so this this
is one of the smaller ones we
had here is everything that you'll find
in an Australian Hungry Jacks that you
won't find in an American Burger King
and here's everything you can get at a
burger king/ Hungry Jacks in America you
can't get in Australia let's get into
the burgers I have to say my observation
in all of this is all of these Burgers
not only are they massive but they look
really good we have a Whiskey River
Whopper got onion you've got lettuce
you've got you have chips inside you
have tomatoes two layers of cheese two
Burger W
patties I really like this I really
really like this the burger are better
at hry Jacks so there's a saying in
Australia it's one of the slogans and
they always say the burgers are better
in Hungry Jacks and this is really good
I can't taste like whiskey specifically
I don't know if it's um I'm not drunk
yet so I think um there's not whiskey in
there but I think it must be like a
whiskey glaze or a Whiskey sauce it's
like a caramelized flavor we have these
exclusive us Burgers starting all the
way down there a Texas Double Whopper
same as a regular Double Whopper but
this one has
jalapenos
teas okay so you get you're getting your
money those also bacon in there too all
right pretty good I don't know if I get
a whole one of those but I like that we
have a double Whiskey River
Whopper an ultimate Double Whopper which
is two layers of beef and two layers of
cheese we have your classic Whopper a
Double Whopper and cheese a triple
Whopper and cheese and an angry
Whopper and it comes with a single Patty
or a double Patty or there's a triple
beef option if that's what you like end
with angry
onions I don't know what an angry onion
is I've never met an angry onion before
all right let's have a bite of the Angry
Whopper there's a bit of a spice to it
nothing too overpowering it's quite nice
I like this as well but that's really
like a nice subtle kick to it so that's
what makes it Angry if you're wondering
I'm so happy I could solve that problem
for you because I'm here to serve if
double meat isn't enough for you we also
have the triple Whopper
Australia yes you are correct that is a
bun then a piece of meat and then
another piece of meat and then a third
piece of meat and then all the
stuff he's jump in the middle of meat
you can't just go meep meep meep uh our
Whopper doesn't automatically have
cheese you can get a Whopper with cheese
obviously um so this one doesn't have
cheese Texas did have cheese um I don't
know why cheese is the default for the
Whopper the Whopper has been around for
so long back when people wanted regular
hamburgers and that cheeseburgers we
think it's just insanity and then we
have the bacon Deluxe um this is very
similar to the ultimate Double Whopper
the sizing is the main difference that I
can tell and obviously with the patties
and stuff stuff but the flavor is
supposed to be the same uh we also have
the the barbecue bacon Whopper Junior
which of course has bacon American bacon
now's the perfect time I know that she
was talking about closeup to the bacon
so why don't I just do a little
something right here for all right all
right check it out Australia American
bacon we got the strip bacon also got a
good glammer SH now we're big we got the
strips we got the strips so the bacon in
Hungry Jacks is australi eye bacon and
it looks something like this if you can
manage to see it past all this sauce um
I know you guys in America generally
prefer your bacon to be a bit crispier
and thinner we do have that option here
however our rashes of bacon do tend to
be quite um a thicker portion so it it
is thin and crispy on the outside but
the inside see how it's like a it's a
nice bit of pork speaking of bacon we
have the bacon King it feels like this
just a Whopper without the vegetables
which I applaud look everyone they put
cheese in between the meats see they
know how to do it this is great I don't
know why it say to be a whole different
menu thing just called this the this
should be the Whopper and then we have a
whoer junior and cheese little baby
whoer and then a triple cheeseburger and
a barbecue cheeseburger moving on to the
much smaller Burgers look at this man
new tiny little Guys bacon cheeseburger
if you want a little more meat in your
mouth and you know I do go ahead and get
yourself the double yo
Australia look at that cheese pole it's
like an Insider video from 3 years ago I
have no idea what rode if rodeos exist
outside of the states or the Americas uh
and if they don't we have a thing called
rodeos and for some reason we have a
rodeo burger and that's just a
cheeseburger with barbecue sauce and
onion rings and now we have our Grill
Master collection so this is made from
thick juicy Angus starting off to my
right we have the grilled Masters pulled
pork and Angus they went hard on the
pulled pork they didn't shy away from
that you can taste the barbecue sauce
which is surprising because it didn't
look like there was much barbecue sauce
on it the pork flavor is coming through
ever so slightly but it's just a texture
of the pulled pork and a solid beef
patty that I don't really like that much
we have our Grill Master Cowboy Angus we
have our Grill Master double Cowboy
Angus with two Angus patties and then we
have our Grill lasses Chicago Angus
Patty double bacon natural cheese and
peppercorn sauce I'm also curious to
know like why do they make a Chicago
burger what is a Chicago Burger is
Chicago a peppery City I thought it was
the windy city has a Patty it's got some
lettuce iceberg lettuce a sauce which I
presume has pepper in it obviously
otherwise don't know what that black
stuff is in it that would be
questionable and it has layer of cheese
and
bacon and tomatoes I think maybe the
reason it's a Chicago style burger is
cuz the double bacon I know in the early
part of last century the Stockyards
really popular in Chicago up in Sinclair
wrote a book about it called the jungle
Del read it it's a real bummer
this is I prefer this to that this has a
lot more flavor the textures are good I
like the combination of the bacon and
the Angus beef it's really messy though
so don't take someone out on a first
date and get the Chicago burger and now
we have our Grill Masters Angus bacon
and cheese and then the grill masters
double Angus bacon and cheese so there's
two Angus putties and two layers of
cheese I just have to say I am really
impressed by Hungry Jacks I find that
their burgers are really really good and
the the quality is unreal here are all
the chicken options exclusive over here
in the US down here we have the BK Royal
crispy chicken Royal the Burger King
Royal the BK Royal fit
for
King Phil
Charles Australia I know if you're aware
of this but there's a chicken sandwich
civil war going on this country every
single fast food place has there a
chicken sandwich I think Chick-fil-A
just came in got everyone scared every
fast food place every burger place has
at least four chicken sandwiches
sometimes more and Burger King I got to
say they did a good job been sitting for
a minute still crispy very impressive
crispy in the title here are all the
chicken options that you can get at
Hungry Jack The Whiskey River Jack Fried
Chicken so you have some lettuce you
have your Whiskey sauce with
some chips onion ring maybe the spicy BK
Royal crispy chicken Sando generous with
the Mayo they're moving Mayo at BK
they're moving Mayo everything is
dripping with mayo I don't
mind it's got more heat than I thought
it
would nothing that I can't handle but
yeah the whiskey rivot grilled chicken
the classic Jax Fried Chicken this is
just fried chicken with some mayonnaise
and some iceberg lettuce the spicy
Jack's fried chicken and it has spicy
sauce on that Australia we also have a
bacon and swiss BK Royal Krispy Chicken
Sandwich and here it
is it's good it's a good combo that's
really good I like that I probably would
get that one over all the other ones the
cheesy bacon classic Jack Fried Chicken
the cheesy bacon spicy Jax Fried Chicken
so this would be the spicy sauce that's
a lot of spicy sauce the spicy grilled
chicken the grilled chicken the grilled
chicken with bacon and cheese and of
course this little guy the chicken
Junior if you've ever had a MC chicken
it's the same exact
thing whoa what's going on here that
sauce or is that like started skimping
on no cuz Ma's on
top what's
that no licking
it a it his mail I know what it is I
want to try the cheesy bacon Spicy Jack
Fried Chicken because I haven't been
able to get like a spicy burger and this
looks like it
is packed with spice so let's take a
bite into it and see how spicy it really
is that is very spicy definitely
recommend this one this one's really
really good it's such a relief because I
feel like every burger that we've had is
like says it's spicy but it's
like where and last but not least we
have some additional exclusive items at
the Burger King we have a big fish which
is our fish sandwich Rivals of course
the fileo fish a square piece of fish
looks a little rough right I like how it
tastes fileo fish is better but I get
down on on a big fish remember those
chicken sandwiches from before we got
them in wrap form the three wraps to
choose from uh so first we have is the
classic crispy wrap sorry half a chicken
breast half come on guys you really cut
it in half can't give us the whole one
may lettuce
tomato nope this one is a spicy
one here's the other half again half a
chicken bre I don't know what the price
point is but you're definitely getting
half of the chicken you get in Sandwich
form we do have a couple of plant-based
options at our Burger King um they're
not vegan though because they are cooked
in the same Grill as the beef burgers
and still contain dairy and eggs just h
Burger King M that one The Impossible
Whopper which we have here there's also
the single impossible King good and get
it for this one what does the burger
tastes like you ask Australia well first
let's take a look at
it sometimes it looks like beef and
sometimes like now it does not has mayo
on here I'm certain it's not a vegan
may it tastes like a Whopper cuz a
Whopper is swimming in male and they add
something to the meat to make it taste
like a Char grilled I mean I think that
everything together because of the
toppings and the way that they prepare a
Whopper and an impossible Whopper are
the same so I would think yeah maybe
side by side I could tell a difference
but right now this tastes exactly like a
Whopper but if we just isolate the
meat you can do taste a difference in
just the meat so I know my favorite if
you really if you're a vegetarian or
Regan well get away the mail if you're
not eating meat I would say that the
plant-based Whopper to me is probably
the closest to the real thing as far as
plant-based fast food things are
concerned that's my personal opinion we
actually have two plant-based burgers
and a fully vegan burger the vegan
Whopper and cheese double vegan Patty
vegan cheese vegan mayo and the Patty is
made from Veg we have a plant-based
Whopper a plant-based Whopper cheese the
cheese is not vegan the plant-based
Angry Whopper our vegan options are
actually vegan as they're cooked
separately from the meat patties which
is really good because if you're a vegan
oret turn and you want to come and get a
good feed then you know it's definitely
vegan this is the best place to go to
yeah so have a good feed in Australian
means how do I a good feed like enjoy
your meal if you want to have a good
meal if you want to enjoy your meal
let's try this vegan wppa cheese double
vegan
Patty this is a good option if you did
want an
alternative I like this and if you just
didn't want any meat
it's it's very feeling there's a lot of
flavor it's it's got like a Herby taste
to it um you can taste the
onion the cheese is good too I was going
to try the cheese separately just to see
if that adds any
flavor the cheese is just a bit creamy
creamy texture a bit more of like a
smokey flavor subtle Smokey flavor
throughout on to the sides Australia you
don't have these chicken fries get a
load of this isn't this a great idea
looks like a Fri right na na na na this
is a piece of chicken they come in I
don't know how many different options we
got the four piece and it came in a bag
usually comes in a fun little box but
whatever these things are fantastic
mozzarella
sticks come in four and eight pieces no
way this no way I can do this pull he's
been sitting for a minute
wait yo no comes with marinara sauce our
BK also has applesauce but uh they
unfortunately forgot it so so uh no
sauce and in Australia these are our
exclusive sides we have a three nuggets
and chip carry cup and we have a Popp
and chicken carry cup and a Popp and
chicken carry cup plenty pack however
those were not available but we do have
a load of other sauces you know what
that means sauce talk sauce talk now
we're going to talk about all the sauces
we have that are exclusive to Australian
Hungary Jacks starting with a Barbe plum
sauce aoli and it's aoli is not just
garlic Mayo traditionally it's made with
garlic and olive oil whereas Mayo uses
oil and egg yolks and then we have our
spicy sauce how spicy is it I'm about to
tell you right now because I'm going to
crack into this let's
go it's not that spicy I think it comes
after it is spicy barbecue plum
never heard of a barbecue Plum
before that's really good it's sweet
it's got that sweet Plum kind of jam
marmalade flavor but with that barbecue
sauce through it but I feel like the
plum taste comes through more I really
like that all right
barbecue fantastic honey
mustard this okay here's our Ranch
America is obs with
ranch I of course am not I'll try it
yeah it's fine all Ranch this the same
moving on we got buffalo
sauce so we got zesty sauce Australia I
don't know if this is just for dipping
stuff or if that's an a
burger I don't think I've heard of this
before maybe we had it before in other
food Wars I just don't remember see how
zesty it is oh man that is zesty it's
like a strong mustard but also
creamy a brown mustard also we have
Sweden sour sauce more for nuggets than
it is for fries but why not
right and before the marinara you know I
love we have other sauces you get here
in the US including stacker sauce
mustard and mayo tartar sauce Royal
sauce King Charles's favorite and a
spicy glaze sauce Hungry Jack also has
some Brey options just no Brey is short
for breakfast here in Australia if
you're aware we love to shorten our work
so we will call afternoon AO we'll call
a snag for a sausage taka is dinner back
to the items here here we have a bacon
and egg Turkish Brey roll we have our
sausage and egg Turkish Brey roll we
have our Jack Brey roll we have our
barbecue Brey wrap and we have our big
Bry wrap which is the same as that one
it just has hash browns in it and then
we have pancakes and and on to our
cheese Toasties a cheese toasty we have
ham and cheese Toasties and a ham cheese
and tomato toasty us we love our fast
food breakfast or Brey as you call it in
Australia starting down here we have
french toast sticks freies I guess you
get them three or five has this nice
little syrupy dipping sauce they're just
okay uh we have a lot of breakfast
sandwiches in the US you can get a
breakfast sandwich in different bread
form the first one we have is a biscuit
don't know if you have these in
Australia try to explain it to non-
Americans what American biscuits are
easier just to show you you have KFC
right it's like those biscuits you get
at KFC um we have these breakfast
sandwiches see this little thing it's
like the driest thing in the world but
we have breakfast sandwiches here's a
bacon egg and cheese one uh you also get
sausage egg and cheese ham egg and
cheese good dry I really don't go for
those but I do like are the CR
sandwiches another bread option where is
a croissant yes a croissant France and
we stuck a bunch of meat and cheese
inside of it going to go with the this
one is the bacon one a fully
loaded
sausage and ham and bacon oh my goodness
every version of pork in one sandwich
with eggs I have I have to
know kind of wish I didn't kind of wish
I didn't biscuits or croissants these
are the ones you can get I'm going to
throw on screen the whole list of both
the options that you have uh can't list
them all it's just a different version
of the bread with a meat an egg and a
cheese
also breakfast burritos believe it this
one W yo dog this is a hefty boy this I
believe is the eggnormous burrito come
on this thing is like this has got to be
this is like a Chipotle burrito look at
the size of this thing Yulie see what's
inside Australia I assure you this is
not normal uh hash browns bacon sausage
an egg cheese it also comes
with a Picante salsa which we will find
out together oh it
is breakfast burritos are a big thing in
America probably in the UK as well but
this is just
ridiculous it's really good and you know
what secret weapon the salsa I don't
know who makes the salsa but yeah dude
I'm I'm having a comeback right now if
you want a breakfast burrito in not
gigantic form there's also a breakfast
burrito Junior got yourself a sweet
tooth we have two exclusive desserts in
the US right here two chocolate chip
cookies also we have this Hershey's
Sunday pie Sunday pie on the go look at
this thing look at this thing you see
that
Yulie I'm kind of mad now they know this
exists I'm going to want it all the time
and at Hungry Jacks these are our
dessert options we have a storm bof
which wasn't available um a storm bubble
gum a storm Oreo a storm CAD flake a
storm M&M's mini a sticky day pudding a
caramel sunde a strawberry sundae a
chocolate sunde and a mini drumstick
vanilla storms if you're not too
familiar I would say it's quite similar
to a McFlurry the bubblegum looks a
little bit terrifying I really want to
try it it looks kind of gross with the
marshmallows on top it looks
ridiculously sweet this is all that I
had to try my ice cream
with that was so sweet it was putrid it
was foul I didn't even think a child
would like that that
is- it can't go wrong with an Oreo I
always get them but a flake will be good
good the the chocolate is a bit
shredded that is a bit of me that is a
bit of me mhm nice creamy and then a
delicious Taste of flaky milk chocolate
burst of flavor in your mouth not
overpowering and not feeling like you're
going to have to end up in the ER
because you have a heart attack I've
even added some more storm flakes to the
base of the ice cream so
amazing m m even though the M&M's have
melted this is really yum M&M's always a
good choice I like the M&M stor this is
this the date the sticky date it's
living up to the Australian name right
now it's really hot here we're just
about to get into summer and the sticky
date did in fact not make it from the
journey from Hungry Jacks to the studio
so this is what we've got a nice sgy
Stricker D I've tried a caramel Sunday
before caramel Sundays are really really
popular here caramel in general really
popular but let's give a strawberry
Sunday a
crack yeah just tastes like a strawberry
Sunday this drumstick here actually
launched in Australia in
1963 and Peters is a classic Australian
brand so this is a national
Australian dessert one could say lot of
us drinks the be okay starting right
down there a specific bottle of water
this Pure Life Nestle Water I should
drink this I'm not going to we also have
dyed
Coke I don't diet got Dr Pepper yeah the
dock M delicious a minimade lemonade
this is I believe root
beer and other drinks you can get for
the kids little apple juice they have
these things Frozen Fanta Wild Cherry
it's normally a slushy that would been
filled up to here but as melted there's
also a frozen Coke same thing but
Coca-Cola flavored um it's just a melted
mess you can get a regular coffee and an
ice coffee this is the vanilla one I
think hang this is the yes the vanilla
ice
coffee
God it's like all vanilla too much yeah
bottle of milk kind of weird but also
Burger King has these two shakes Oreo
shake and a chocolate shake yes Oreo
like the cookie and this shake is so
fantastic and here's why it isn't a
vanilla shake with chocolate it's like
the the cream flavor flavored Shake
M it's so good M you can also get a
chocolate version too a chocolate Oreo
shake to chocy this is the one this is
the the best one other drinks you can
get at the BK in the US we couldn't get
where I just didn't feel like bringing
is Sprite Zero uh unsweeten diced tea
simply orange juice frozen Fanta blue
raspberry drink uh Powerade Zero High SE
fruit punch and Mellow Yellow these are
the drinks that we have at Hungry Jacks
we have vanilla Coke Fanta raspberry
Mount Franklin Spring Water Biscoff
Shake bubblegum Shake caramel Shake
strawberry shake orange juice and Cary
apple juice we have some frozen drinks
with bures which come in a few different
flavors we have a Frozen fanter and
grape Frozen fanter sour watermelon
Frozen Fanta mango and Frozen Fanta
raspberry there's also an option to add
bursties to the frozen drinks they come
in these flavors our spiders come in a
frozen Fanta grape spider for Frozen
Fanta sour watermelon spider a frozen
Fanta mango spider a frozen Fanta
raspberry spider and a frozen Coke
spider I'm going to go with the
raspberry spider that's one thing I love
about Hungry Jacks their ice cream is
legit like their ice cream is so thick
look at
that I like that I don't like the
bursties with it the bures did nothing
for me it's just a pop of flavor but
there's nothing it's just a waste really
I think the ice the spider tastes great
just with the fan with the raspberry
fanil I'm sure that in America you guys
have spiders as well but you probably
don't call it
that I'm not a fan of the
bursties I find that a frozen Coke like
this the ice cream tastes really good
with the coke on its own the added
texture and taste of a bursty was just
useless it was kind of a throwaway it
made it less Pleasant Jack's Cafe menu
has a few options uh a cappuccino a flat
white a latte a long black which wasn't
available a mocha hot chocolate chai
latte Dilma tea fancy um a mini Chino
and a piccolo which weren't available a
machiato and a short black an ice long
black which wasn't available a caramel
fudge ice coffee an iced chocolate an
iced marker and an iced chai and for the
iced drinks there's an option to add
brown sugar popping
pearls that doesn't sound good to me but
I'm going to try it anyway it sounds
like it's going to be really really
sweet so we're going to try the caramel
fudge ice
coffee oh my God my hate it I hate that
but I want why why ruin a perfectly good
iced coffee with these bursties Hungry
Jacks I really appreciate you trying to
be Innovative and trying to jump on that
whole Boba sensation that's happening
but
um you don't don't ruin a good thing
You' got a really good thing going your
coffee is are great well they're
good so for those of you who haven't
heard of hungry Jacks before it first
opened up in Perth Australia in
1971 you see Burger King wanted to open
restaurants in Australia but the name
Burger King had already been trademarked
by a local restaurant in Adelaide
because Burger King actually had never
trademarked it down under a wealthy
businessman Jack powin acquired the
rights to the Australian Burger King
franchise and decided to name it Hungary
Jack Hungary Jack and Burger King
actually went to court in 2001 due to
Burger King wrongfully trying to
terminate an agreement in 1990 which
allowed Hungry Jacks to open and develop
Burger King franchises in Australia the
development agreement as it was named
meant Hungary Jacks had to open a
minimum of four restaurants per year in
certain parts of Australia Burger King
began working with shell to Market its
own restaurant outlets in Australia in a
relationship that excluded Jacks which
was not made aware of this until a year
later that was in
1995 in
1995 Burger King withdrew the approval
for thirdparty franchises to open which
meant that Hungry Jacks could not stick
to the development agreement eventually
Hungary Jacks actually won the battle
and the judge ruled that Burger King had
been breaching the contract an agreement
was made to Rebrand the new Burger King
restaurants in in Australia into Hungary
Jack as a sole Master franchise even
though Australia is a huge country it's
still doesn't have as many Hungry Jacks
restaurants compared to the number of
Burger King restaurants globally there's
only 452 Hungry Jacks and that is as of
September
2023 that's right there's more than
18,700 Burger King restaurants around
the world that's 42 times more than
Hungry Jacks Texas is actually the state
with the most Burger King restaur
restaurant at
583 as of September 2023 this year
however two of Burger King's largest
franchise have filed for bankruptcy due
to low sales and high costs and Burger
King announced that it will be closing a
few hundred stores later this year in
August of this year Burger King was
faced with a lawsuit over the size of
its Whoppers compared to what's in the
menu the lawsuit alleged that the
Whopper looked 35% larger with more than
double the meat in the advertisement
compared to the Whopper customers
actually received in response to the
claim a spokesperson for Burger King
said that Patty's featured in its ads
are the same ones used and the Whoppers
served all over this great nation no way
that's true but moving on I mean the
fact that Burger King sells 2.1 billion
Whoppers every year tells me the
advertisement's working so all right
it's not the same size whatever you wait
it get out with your life Hungary Jacks
also faced a lawsuit in 2020 when
McDonald's tried to sue over its
creation of the Bing Jack which
McDonald's claimed was very similar to
the big Mark I can understand the
similarities there both parties were
expected to return to court as a at a
later date but the Big Jack was dropped
from the menu so it seems a disagreement
may have been resolved McDonald's is
definitely Hungry Jack's biggest
competitor with over a thousand
restaurants but word on the street is
Wendy is going to expand in Australia
although there has been a mixed response
about that entering here McDonald's is
the number one competitor against Burger
King possibly because it has more
locations about 40,000 more as of 2022
which over doubl the amount of Burger
Kings McDonald's has always been larger
despite both chains starting around the
same year in the 1950s McDonald's is
just optimized for business domination
Burger King I can't believe there's this
many Burger Kings to be honest
McDonald's is the king they do
everything right they always done
everything right uh Burger King has just
been looking at McDonald's and trying to
copy what they do I'm not a big Burger
King fan I love McDonald's uh McDonald's
fries way better right at the gate uh
the burger selection McDonald's way
better more convenient better service
yeah I I love Hungry Jacks I I recently
have been consuming more Hungry Jacks
than any other fast food I like Hungry
Jacks the burgers are really good I like
the meat I like the produce the good
thing about Hungry Jacks is you can take
tast the difference in the quality of
meat there's it is definitely far more
Superior in the make it's a bit more of
a step up from your average
cheeseburgers I think a lot of Aussies
perceive Hungry Jacks as something we
grew up with it definitely even though
it's the exact same thing as Burger King
Hungry Jacks for us resemble something
that's Australian or an Australian take
on American Burgers and American fast
food chains
let's talk about price in Australia our
waart is $920 Australian dollars which
is
$63 USD make it a meal with medium fries
and a medium Coke it'd be $16.40 AUD or
$10.75 USD in the US a Whopper will cost
you
$6.89 that makes our Whopper 2% more
expensive if you want to make it a meal
with a A medium drink drink gge and a
medium fry this whole thing will cost
you
$12.18 that's an 18% increase in price
it looks like our menu might be a little
bit cheaper than the US I think the
prices at Hungary Jacks are quite
reasonable there are a lot of fast food
chains around that are quite expensive
for what you're getting and I always
think that the price of Hungry Jacks is
really quite competitive yeah you know
what 12 something for this that seems
like a pretty good deal um I'm seeing
all these news stories about about fast
food is suddenly not cheap anymore it
used to be a lot less expensive but I
still think 12 something for all this I
could definitely get full on all this so
yeah this is a pretty good
deal we took a look at the most cfic
items on Hungry Jack's menu in Australia
this is the grill Master's double Cowboy
Angus coming in at
1,41 calories however if you got the
triple cheeseburger super super stunner
Meal which comes with small fries a
small Coke a mini drumstick three
chicken nuggets that would come to
1,386 calories which is still less than
the burger and with 15 calories
remaining for the US it's the bacon King
as the most calorific single menu item
coming in at
1200 calories let's get the rest of the
stats on the screen there if you were to
get a cheeseburger meal with a small fry
and small drink Coke and a four piece
nugget and a soft served cone that's
only 86 calories more than just this
bacon
King unfortunately us Burger King does
not disclose its ingredients online or
off however the hungry JS website does
have a full list of ingredients and we
found some pretty interesting stuff the
cheese in the plant-based whoer isn't
actually fully
vegetarian as it contains products
derived from cows more specifically it
contains carves rent which is a type of
lining of the stomach and as a type of
enzyme commonly used in a lot of cheeses
to help separate the curds and whey in
the cheese making process Liars we
trusted you so if you actually want to
avoid animal products be sure to specify
vegan Whopper when you order not just a
plant-based Whopper a lot of ingredients
like to use big scientific names which
sound a little scary such as
tar I can't even say that tooer tooro
but this is just another word for
vitamin E why not just say that and it
is found in foods such as vegetable oils
nuts and leafy greens and we also found
in barbecue sauce there's Rochester
sauce I don't even know what a Rochester
sauce is I know what a Rottweiler is and
that's a dog Rochester Source I'm not
too familiar with that I
am what is that on green Jacks still
rolling all
right starting to lose it it's that time
uhuh all right